you know what else is cool the Jonas
Brothers announcing their first tour in
nearly a decade and a new song here is
everything you need to know about the
tour it's called the happiness begins
tour you know because that's the name of
their new album they will have two
special guests joining them at bebe
Rexha and Jordan McGraw who just happens
to be dr. Phil's son weird good their
lady loves sophie priyanka and danielle
be joining them too I mean nothing's
really out of the question
it's a North American tour and they are
hitting 40 cities it kicks off in Miami
on August 7th and will end October 20th
at the Hollywood Bowl in a statement the
guy said quote we can't wait for
everyone to see what we have planned I
can't wait either and because I read
press releases check this out they
subtly slid in the name of the third
single off the album only human it's
produced by Shellback who has also
produced songs for some people you may
have heard of just Taylor Swift ariana
grande and Britney Spears and Adele no
big deal the guy's new album is
officially available for pre-order e 2
is with Nic this weekend at the premiere
of ugly dolls
you know I haven't grown up in the
public eye and having experienced my
awkward years in the public eye you get
really used to shaking things off and
understanding that your imperfections
make you who you are and connect us all
in a big way he also dished on next
week's Met Gala he's on the committee
with his wife have you got your Met Gala
outfit together it's come together is it
coming together yeah it's coming
together
to be honest like I am very excited I
love to make out it's always a fun night
but you know Priyanka will set the tone
and I'm just gonna be there to support
so I'll keep it simple at her shine
that's a good hubby all right guys who
is ready for this Jonas Brothers tour I
am I'd like tickets merch the whole
shebang for all the latest on Nick Joe
and Kevin keep it locked with all things
et until next time I'm Katie Krauss and
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]